I felt like a lot of sorority
recruitment is based on looks and it's
like if you see a pretty girl and she's
nice you're going to be like oh I'm so
excited about her she's so cute like
that's a word that a lot of people use
she's so cute she's so pretty it's
pretty privilege is a thing pretty
privilege is such a good country
[Music]
so this one was audience submitted by MD
period empty all right I pay to have
friends
three two one go I knew this was gonna
come up
best best money I ever spent
cancer for real oh I'm sorry
oh it's the wrong one yeah I paid to be
a part of an organization that
introduced me to like really really
amazing women and it's like if that's
what people want to say that's what they
say but like I do it again no yeah I
would be with you on that side if I made
more friends because I am paying it was
really hard because I transferred to my
school and so everyone had been friends
since freshman year and so trying to
like navigate that like social scene
where everyone already knows each other
and they're comfortable with their
friends and they're not actively looking
for more and also like you could pay and
girls could still not like you like it's
not like you're paying you're paying for
the philanthropy you don't pay and then
all of a sudden like oh I have to like
you like there are like probably a
million girls who are in sororities and
don't have friends at all we're all busy
sometimes so I feel like they're we
don't have those moments where we get to
connect as much because I'm considering
Neo still so I'm excited for it to like
you know grow more do you feel like
pushed out since you're a Neo like do
you feel like you have to like work
towards that relationship you know I I
thought that was how it was going to be
in the beginning with mine I feel like
it was actually pretty good I mean it's
a pretty small sorority so going into it
I think they were like more accepting I
think it was more me trying to break
that mind of like I'm still little and
they're still my big sisters like no now
we're equal right yeah
I love to party
three two one go
I do love to party of course it's you
know the getting ready doing hair makeup
and stuff but there's just times where I
don't know I'd just rather be at home
watching a movie chilling with friends I
definitely agree like there's some days
I just want to stay home with all the
violence going on that definitely
determines my thought process of staying
home but yeah okay I like to go out to a
bar with my friends get a little mixy
mixy but I don't want to like go to the
frat house get disgusting smell like the
bo of like 40 men and there's like five
girls there and it's like I don't think
that's necessarily fun I would rather I
don't know if this can be in there but I
would rather be like high than drunk and
I'm not gonna be high because then
you're like analyzing everything around
you and it's like these 19 year old boys
that are just like
[Laughter]
bro
no that's so true about like the whole
drinking culture at my school I go to
San Diego State it's a really big party
school so it's either you block out or
you don't have a good time yeah and I
don't like blocking out I like
remembering what I did the night before
so that's like why I'm on site somewhat
disagree because I don't want to block
out every time I go out I also think if
you're not partying and you're not going
out like you're you're going to become a
ghost it's harder no that is it's harder
to stay relevant like if people don't
see you like they'll forget about you so
some sororities only take pretty people
three two one go
[Music]
I'm like conflicted okay there's a few
sororities at my school that do solid
gold-based soft looks if you're blonde
and you're skinny you're in personally
my sorority doesn't do that I think it's
just a load of bull crap it's so
superficial these kinds of like image
sororities that we're talking about like
that's where they get their power from
like everybody thinking like they're so
pretty or they're so untouchable and I
don't think my sorority is like that but
I I think it matters to my sorority it
sucks but that's just how it is you know
and I think it is because it's a social
institution like it just relies on other
people like feeding into it like
catering to it kind of so the
exclusivity of a lot of sororities is
what makes them like a top house or like
more desired I felt like a lot of
sorority recruitment is based on looks
and it's not maybe something that people
are even like conscious of but like if
you see a pretty girl and she's nice
you're going to be like oh I'm so
excited about her she's so cute like
that's a word that a lot of people use
she's so cute she's so pretty it's like
pretty privilege is a thing pretty
privilege is such a thing yeah so I
mainly had more experiences with
Multicultural sororities mine is
Multicultural one I mean there's a part
of me I'm plus size and I was really
scared for a second that I wasn't gonna
get accepted or something because I am
plus-sized but I mean I've seen other
plus-sized people in the Multicultural
sororities and I'm like okay if they're
part of it then I definitely have a
chance so yeah that's why I was kind of
conflicted okay through 12 I grew up in
like very white spaces and so like all I
saw about sororities are like
traditionally like white sororities and
like I didn't see myself in those spaces
and like it was very clear that like if
someone like me is not in the room
there's a reason why and so when I got
to my school and like you know when you
all just like are all black like it just
has like a different type of feeling
like you feel like more seen and like
understood because of like you know
Common circumstances the image doesn't
necessarily have to do with like your
physical appearance like looking to put
together all the time it's more of like
how you peer to people on the outside
like when we are going through
recruitment or just in general like you
can't post red Solo cups you can't post
alcohol if you're under 21. I think it's
something different though like posting
alcohol and like looking like a mess
because just like real world like you
don't want you 19 like drunk on
Instagram like when you're trying to get
a job so like my sorority does care
about that and it's not it's not so much
like they're trying to control me but
it we just should be like that you just
shouldn't post alcohol if you're not
yeah exactly sorry I don't know how to
read this I feel like when the Frat Bros
like post up with their Kegs and their
red Solo cups it's fine but it feels
like a little bit misogynistic that like
a girl needs to look classy and she
can't drink alcohol but like the boys
can do it and like
why is that a thing yeah like I have to
look like this like lady and the sort of
definitely upholds that you know yeah
yeah yes they reinforce it but it's also
like when you go into the world like
you're not gonna solve misogyny because
you're like I'm gonna post this cup and
I'm boss up it's just like no like at
the end of the day when you apply for a
job they're Googling you they're going
on your Instagram and they're seeing who
you are and they're not thinking about
sexism when they see you with a red solo
cup
I've been made to do things I'm
uncomfortable with while in a sorority
three two one
[Music]
I didn't do anything like crazy that's
disrespectful to my body but going in
front of a panel in front of hundreds of
other sorority girls just conquering
that fear being on stage that's
something I had to do that was
uncomfortable for me
um so it's a different way of how you
perceive it yeah that's how I was taking
the question as well it's just like I've
had like a lot of social anxiety and
like even talking to like older women in
my sword you're like that is really
uncomfortable for me but like once I
like pushed through and I talk to them
I'm like damn you are so fire like I
can't believe I was nervous so a
consequence of being vice president I
had to send girls to collections and
stuff like that if potentially let's say
they didn't pay or whatever like I don't
like doing that like I don't like like
messing with people's money or I guess
in that kind of way like that's like
when I've been forced to do some
actually Force like binded by contract
to do something I'm very uncomfortable
with like that was kind of like knife to
my throat the reason why I'm on someone
disagrees not because I've been made to
do things that are uncomfortable I think
I've been made to do things that I'm
like I don't get the point I don't see
why we need to do this it doesn't make
sense is there anything in particular I
can't really say because it's the during
bloodship process totally but it was
just stuff like little stuff like that
where it's like not harming me or
anything but I just I I don't see the
reason why for it I was just wondering
how did you guys interpret the question
did you guys interpret it like more like
hazing they'd tell us each year in our
conference that there's there was a
school years ago who would tie these
girls up and they were forced to walk
out in the ocean and find a way to untie
themselves so for the viewers out there
don't get it twisted like there's a lot
of girls out there who do things that
they are absolutely is a disgrace to
their body and I want the viewers to
know that um you never is never that
serious I also feel like I have a unique
experience like in my sorority because
I'm queer and like majority of my line
sisters are not and so like when I'm in
those spaces people are like
you really gay girl and I'm just like uh
I might swing you away but I'm not
swinging your way like you're not my cup
of tea so it's just like that discomfort
or like the invalidation of like a part
of my identity because someone think
they're entitled to like I don't know
what my time or is like frustrating no
yeah now that I'm older I've grown so
much from like being a Freshman and now
I'm a junior so like my freshman year if
you were to ask question I would have
said yeah I felt uncomfortable because
you have Junior and senior guys praying
on 17 18 year olds and it's gross and
like you feel Under Pressure because
like oh like this older guy's talking to
me and he wants me to do this so I'm
gonna do that even though you don't
really want to but it's a way to get
invited back to a party and like get to
know people but now that I'm older and I
go to the fraternities that I feel the
most comfortable at and know that if
something were to happen to me or any of
my friends like they would take care of
it I don't really feel uncomfortable
anymore drugs and like alcohol make
people do really weird things and like
touch you weird and it's just it's
really disgusting and it's hard like
when you're in their house like they
they like Empower each other you know
like and I wonder like kind of like
turns into like a pissing contest like
all of them like trying to like Alpha
each other like it's like a lot but I
don't know it's also kind of fun like if
you like are somewhere safe right like I
literally you're so chaotic
I don't
worry about money three two one
[Music]
first of all with the Multicultural
organizations for the viewers it's
definitely a lot more cheaper than the
panhellenix so that's kind of the main
reason why I joined I'm low income
that's like obvious and
it's just hard sometimes because I do
love this org and I want to stay in it
but there are times where I have to
think future wise am I going to have to
go in active am I going to have to
actually leave because I don't have
money to even do this and that's pretty
upsetting and so everybody being a story
is a lot of money we can all agree yeah
it's a lot of money and I've experienced
that like I've gone inactive not because
I wanted to but because I couldn't
afford you know to Shell out a thousand
dollars a quarter so last year I tried
to apply for scholarships I did feel a
little bit misled during the recruitment
process about like Financial
transparency I don't think it's on
specific people but I think not being
educated enough about your own chapter
and then bringing other people into and
being like yeah we have scholarships and
it's like okay you do but you you have
to pay for the whole year first but I'm
lucky in that like my president last
year was amazing and she worked with me
to get me on special status I could be
inactive I could still be a part of the
chapter like my best friend can bring me
to things but it's something to consider
and I do feel like the finances of Greek
life are what make it so inaccessible to
so many people so I'm lucky my chapter
is very
um flexible with dues like I'm it's such
a blessing like that's that's so
terrible and I'm so sorry but the social
aspect of the sorority is like the most
expensive part for me like oh my God
like outfits and then Ubers and drinks
at the bar and nobody's forcing me to do
these things but you want to hang out
with your sisters you want to be around
them and like when you're going through
Rush nobody's telling you that like dues
I was prepared for I'd signed up for but
I had no idea how much like the social
part of it would be yeah I think a lot
of people don't talk about that because
there's a good chunk of people that
don't pay anything out of their own bank
accounts and it's like their parents
which if you can do that I'm jealous
like I wish that I had that kind of
support yeah that's my situation yeah
I'm super blessed and thankful that my
parents do pay for my dues they do pay
for obviously not the social aspect of
it but if I like need to dress for an
event or if I need stuff for like
recruitment they'll help me out in that
regard we have this whole financial plan
figured out and how they see it is
essentially like an investment in my
future because of what I will get out of
being a part of the sorority the reason
why I'm on somewhat agree and not on
agree is because I took it in like two
different perspectives one is like my
own financial status but also I was on
my sororities because I could be bored
and we don't have a lot of money people
think sororities are like unlimited
funds like we have so much money to
spend like ridiculous amounts of dollars
on stupid things but my sorority is not
like that at all like we struggled with
dues and stuff because people don't pay
their dues either yeah they just like to
join and they don't pay the dues and
then we don't have any money to do
anything with that so I do worry about
the financial status of my chapter I
agree with you what you were saying like
I'm fortunate to have parents who'll pay
my dues my outfits everything I need
being an African-American based sorority
um the women will are not hesitant on
helping you out for any funds that you
need I have a question real quick for
you guys when you guys go through
recruitment do they give you like a
financial transparency sheet that like
lays out everything no absolutely not
wow really it's not transparent because
nobody would rush like nobody would join
if they knew how much I mean I'm sure
some people would but with our sorority
so they are very flexible and I am
thankful for that but they weren't as
transparent with that because we are
like my story is Latina base and so
obviously a lot of them come in first
gen low income and we never want you to
feel discouraged like oh now I can't
join because of money yeah which makes
sense absolutely but I also think there
should be a part where we're like okay
well let me be realistic to you yeah
yeah this was submitted by Teo racism
exists within sororities
[Music]
for my sortie first black
African-American sorority out there we
prefer to stick with our people but
we're always welcome to branching out to
Multicultural perspective but I think
there's a sorority for everything you'll
have your Multicultural sororities
predominantly white sororities and we
have our predominantly black sorties
yeah I would agree with that I think
it's just empowering to be in a space
where you're poured into by people who
are successful and look like you that's
like extremely honestly life-changing
like and if someone from a different
ethnicity wanted to join like my
personal perspective is just like simply
why like I'm not gonna yeah it's just
like well not why like you can't be here
I'm just like I'm just genuinely
interested in knowing why like if
someone was adopted and grew up in a
black family and that's all they know
it's like okay like girl come on like I
I fully understand that so it's not like
there's like a don't join this it's just
more so this is a safe space and as a
person who is not a black woman why are
you wanting to enter our safe space
right because there's a lot of spaces
for us elsewhere yeah yeah absolutely
great I think sororities do a good job
at reinforcing beauty standards that are
definitely racial in their roots and
like have existed for a long time and
we're set by people who aren't alive
anymore I guess and I think sororities
feed into each other reinforcing these
beauty standards like this like typical
skinny white girl like this blonde so I
think in that kind of way it's a problem
and it's terrible it's It's upsetting I
mean I had a friend who goes to a
different School than I do you know
obviously I like being a story so I'll
tell people like oh if you've ever
thought about it you should definitely
try it she said that there's this one
story that because she's Latina that was
like making fun of her in a way and
being like Oh I know you know how to
cook nachos and blah blah I know you
know how to cook and stuff like that and
it's just like so upsetting because it's
like now you're ruining it for the rest
of us like for the people that actually
want these people to join and like
aren't trying to make this a safe space
like you guys are saying and now because
someone else wants to act like racist
and stupid now it's making the rest of
us look bad I know some sororities that
do select people of color to join just
to look better they don't really
genuinely care and it's really sad and
it's disgusting it's performative
activism yeah it's someone not wanting
to get scrutinized for being racist so
they do what looks not race basis but at
the end of the day like you don't have
honest or Genuine intentions behind the
decisions you're making like a black
face in a high place doesn't equal like
inclusivity like that's just not how it
works and like I'm super thankful like
in my chapter we um do have our we call
it like our Betty chair belonging Equity
diversity inclusion she is a person of
color and she is so well educated and
just really brings us really like great
presentations about like the importance
of pronouncing someone's name like
African-American vernacular like you
know like just bringing awareness to
things that I usually don't really think
about and I think that in my chapter
like specifically we're making the right
steps what if she was white do you think
that she could still achieve the
inclusivity like do you think they have
to be black or my uh I think as long as
someone is like well educated in the
subject they can make a difference but
also I feel like I don't want to
necessarily like say like it means more
when it comes
exactly yeah but you know what else I'm
thinking is it the job of like we also
have an equity and belonging chair but
like is it the job of a black woman to
educate like white people yeah we're all
adults like and maybe it does mean more
coming from a woman of color
but what a burden you know that it has
to be this poor like not I don't mean
poor but like this woman's job to like
educate the rest of her sisters like why
maybe it's a problem within probably
white spaces and maybe it should be the
burden of white people to correct their
own misdoings you know I think an
important question to ask yourself is
who does it feel special to to have that
be a person of color like it feels
special to you but I would like just
like to like challenge you like in your
sorority like to just
possibly like its effort that's simply
all it is like teaching diversity and
inclusivity and so if like you as like
you know a white girl in your sporty can
like put more effort in like learning
certain things so you can teach that and
then asking a person of color like
advice like I think that would be a
great suggestion just you know thank you
so much for saying that and like all of
you guys like had to say like I really
appreciate it and I will straight up
admit like I do have to learn more I do
have to like put in the time and like
educate myself
um and yeah I just really appreciate you
guys thank you I I really like that
suggestion just because it is I would be
a bit hard to find that balance of like
there's a lot of people that are like
well my sorority isn't racist so we're
fine and it's like well yeah you guys
aren't discriminating against people but
you have to do more than just not be
racist like you know what I mean you
have to be anti-racist yeah yeah and you
have to learn from that you have to
acknowledge that Greek life originally
when it was first made is was a racist
system and I think like you're saying it
shouldn't be the job of a person of
color I don't need that pressure I yeah
like yeah I don't know you I don't need
it too and then like when I said that I
didn't mean it like that at all like no
yeah I know I know you didn't mean it
like that I just think that like this is
what happens like in spaces like this
where we like are working towards like
decolonizing like originally white
spaces is that like oftentimes like
white people are made aware of things
they didn't know before and I'm not
sitting here like oh my God you racist
you thought that it's more just like
your product of your environment we
presented you new ideas and thoughts and
like you either take it moving forward
or you don't but then you also live with
this the decision that you make moving
forward too so it's like exactly it's
okay yeah you're good
this was submitted by Rachel I regret
joining a sorority three two one go
oh
it's it's more sometimes it's a burden
for me honestly it's not an all-around
overall like settled regret but I have
my moments but I do like my friends I am
very thankful for them but yeah maybe
it's not enough like to like put up with
everything else like to put up with the
complicity to put up like with
that I don't care about to put up with
gossip
to put up with paying dues so like
hearing people like say things about me
like my sisters that I don't even really
know hearing like not nice things about
yourself is really hard at this point in
time in it for
the connections that I will have after
college because I'm
in my last two quarters of school and
I'm really grateful for the people that
I have met but I do wonder if it was
worth it sometimes I think I strongly
disagree joining AKA has bloomed me to
someone I never thought I could be being
able to articulate my words it's just
made me be surrounded by like
like-minded women like how you were
talking about being in a space where you
don't feel like you're alone so that's
why I strongly disagree yeah like I said
it is life-changing just beyond that
it's like I love my line sisters like
great people forever will be in my life
and then like knowing women that like
poured into my parents because my
parents are immigrants and like they
were like dealt to women so it's like it
was like really like deep for me I
joined the same organization so I'm just
like very happy to be a Delta my
sorority it's not my entire life but
right now it is I live in the sorority
house for the past few years when I went
through recruitment I just felt genuine
connections with these girls I felt like
every conversation was super real and
like they genuinely cared about me I've
also gone through really hard times too
like last year or not last year like
three months ago I lost my aunt to Stage
for lung cancer and then my my high
school boyfriend died
um and so it was really really hard and
like my sisters were there to like Lift
Me Up and motivate me and support me and
not even just like in the really hard
times but also the really good times too
like we're always there to like validate
each other and like lift each other up
and Empower one another and I've just
grown into like such a different person
that I was two years ago and I wouldn't
be who I am today without my chapter
beautiful
[Music]
nice thank you
foreign